The US Plan to Invade Canadа
A time-honored tradition in the U.S. military,
contingency plans have been drawn up for the
defense against, and invasion of, most major
military powers.
In fact, in response to recent events on the
Korean peninsula, the U.S. and South Korea
recently signed on to such a plan.
One of the most interesting episodes in this
rich history of preparing for things that
will probably never happen came when Uncle
Sam planned to invade Johnny Canuck.
Early Planning
In the years leading up to World War II, beginning
in fact in the 1920s, the army began planning
for wars with a variety of countries, designating
each plan by a different color: Germany (black),
Japan (orange), Mexico (green) and England
(red); as a dominion of Great Britain, Canada
(crimson) was presumed to be loyal to England,
and thus was included in the plan against
a supposed British invasion (not to be confused
with that of the 1960s).
The paranoid U.S. military strategists who
devised War Plan Red believed that if the
Britain and America were to battle again,
it would begin from a trade dispute.
Whatever the cause, army planners anticipated
that any war with England would be prolonged,
not only because of British and Canadian tenacity,
but also from the fact that Britain could
draw manpower and resources from its empire,
including at that time Australia, Hong Kong,
India, Kenya, New Zealand, Nigeria, Palestine,
South Africa and Sudan.
Canadian Invasion Plan
Different versions of the plan were proposed,
and one was first approved in 1930 by the
War Department.
It was updated in 1934-1935, and, of course,
never implemented.
Although it was far reaching and addressed
some of Britain’s greatest strengths, such
as the Royal Navy, one of the chief areas
of concern was the U.S.’s long border with
Canada.
As a result, the plan addressed our northern
neighbors with great detail, to wit:
British Columbia
With its vital naval base, military strategists
planned a naval attack on Victoria, launched
from Port Angeles, Washington, as well as
a combined assault on Vancouver and its island.
Successful occupation of this area would effectively
cut off Canada from the Pacific.
Manitoba
The central hub for the Canadian railway system
was located in Manitoba’s capital city,
Winnipeg; army strategists felt that a land
assault could easily be launched from Grand
Forks, North Dakota, and Canada’s rail lines
neutralized.
New Brunswick and Nova Scotia
Military planners apparently hoped to stun
the Maritime Provinces with a poison gas attack
on Nova Scotia’s capital city, Halifax,
then also home to a major naval base.
The chemical battle would then be followed
by a sea invasion at St. Margaret’s Bay.
It that didn’t work, an overland invasion
and occupation of New Brunswick would, hopefully,
isolate the valuable seaports of Nova Scotia
from the remainder of Canada, effectively
stopping British resupply of its forces.
Ontario
A three-pronged attack, arising from Buffalo,
Detroit and Sault Ste.
Marie would gain control of the Great Lakes
for the U.S.
In addition to causing a crushing blow to
British supply lines, it would allow the United
States to control most of Canada’s industrial
production.
Quebec
An overland attack launching from adjacent
New York and Vermont was planned.
Control of this French-speaking province would,
when combined with control of the Maritime
Provinces, stop Britain from having any entry
point to the remainder of the country from
the Eastern seaboard.
Revelation of the Plan
Although it was declassified in 1974, portions
of the plan were inadvertently leaked long
before.
During what was supposed to be classified
testimony by military brass to the House Military
Affairs Committee, two generals revealed some
of the details of War Plan Red.
That testimony was mistakenly published in
official reports, which were picked up and
printed by the New York Times.
Also revealed in the New York Times was the
fact that the United States Congress had assigned
$57 million in 1935 (nearly $1 billion today)
in order to build three air bases near the
U.S./Canadian border in line with War Plan
Red’s recommendations, in case the U.S.
needed to defend against or attack Canada.
These air bases were supposed to be disguised
as civilian airports, but the Government Printing
Office accidentally reported the existence
of the air bases on May 1 of 1935, blowing
their cover.
Interestingly, War Plan Red’s recommendations
also proposed that the U.S. not just invade
in such a war with Britain and Canada, but
take over, adding any conquered regions as
states to the United States.
The Sad History of Americans Invading Canada
Badly
Americans have a history of underestimating
the Canadians:
Revolutionary War
In September 1775, Benedict Arnold (when he
was still on our side) led an unsuccessful
assault on Quebec City overland through difficult
Maine wilderness; over 40% of Arnold’s men
were lost making the attempt, and yet, inexplicably,
he was promoted to Brigadier General.
War of 1812
During the second war with Britain, Thomas
Jefferson opined that to occupy Canada was
a “mere matter of marching” for U.S. troops.
Yet attacks in the Old Northwest, across the
Niagara River, and north from Lake Champlain,
all failed.
Proxy “War” for Ireland
Over a period of five years from 1866 to 1872,
Irish Catholics from the U.S. engaged in a
series of raids on Canadian targets, including
forts and customs houses.
Known as the Fenian raids, the Fenian Brotherhood
had hoped that their actions would force the
British to withdraw from Ireland.
They were unsuccessful.
Post Cold War
In 1995, Michael Moore created a fictional
war between the United States and Canada in
the comedy, Canadian Bacon.
Like the real-life Americans who went before
them, the fictional invasion in this farcical
political commentary failed.
What Comes Around Goes Around
Before you get the idea that only Americans
are aggressive bastards, you should know that
the Canadians had developed a plan to invade
the United States before the U.S. ever started
on its scheme.
Characterized as a counterattack, the 1921
plan more accurately resembles a preemptive
war.
The brainchild of Lieutenant Colonel Buster
Sutherland Brown of the Canadian Army, the
plan called for a surprise attack on the U.S.
as soon as the Canadians had “evidence”
that America was planning an invasion; it
was felt that a preemptive strike was required,
as it would be the only way Canada could prevail
in a battle with its larger, southern neighbor,
which benefited from a far greater arsenal
and much more manpower.
Other advantages of the quick strike included
the fact that the war would be fought on American
territory, so losses in civilian life and
infrastructure would be borne by the Americans.
Finally, the colonel thought this plan would
best buy the Canadians time for their allies,
the British, to come to their rescue before
the Americans could launch an effective counterstrike.
It’s always the quiet ones